my name is paul auster berry I'm the
production designer on the film the
shape of water essentially my job as a
production designers I have to create
the craft the look of the whole movie
everything you see on camera not the
lighting like this off camera lighting
you see you hear everything on camera is
something that we're involved with Viet
cars biet magazines anything people
touches we have to decide you know
sometimes we have to decide what country
we have to shoot in what city usually at
the beginning you read the script and
it's kind of like your client if my
background is an architect so it's like
a client you have to decide what things
might be asset what things are better to
be found on location what things might
be a modification of the location that
kind of thing so it's basically crafting
the whole look to help tell the story
for the director the first thing you do
is break it down I listen basically list
all the locations be a set location or
whatever I don't necessarily decide
which is a location or a build but you
break it down to see what different
locations there are what spaces are
required to tell the story then you know
you come up with an idea of which one's
might be found in a particular place
that you are or not or which one's might
have to be fabricated and then you have
usually you have your meeting with the
director and producer and you see if you
hit it off you know sometimes they they
look at your previous work sometimes
they just want to talk to you about what
you think about their particular script
and how you might proceed and creating
that world from to help tell their story
I don't storyboard the director usually
does deals with the storyboarding
however I do put a lookbook sometimes
together our ideas book we pull pull
references I have you know we all have
large reference libraries and/or the
Internet of course and and then
sometimes you do sketches I prefer to do
3d Sketchup models that's I'm an
architect my background so I'm pretty
good with the three-dimensional world so
it depends what the film is and what
things I mean if it's an invented set
generally you have to do some drawings
but if it's if it's a found kind of
locations you often pull together moods
and and other things that help help you
describe what your vision is yeah I
graduated in Ottawa in Canada in 1989
with a degree in architecture and
ironically I had the REI C which is well
architectural Institute of Canada war
for the student most likely to succeed
in the profession of architecture cut to
two years later I switched over into
film because I worked for a couple years
in in film I mean in architecture and I
met a bunch of people who worked in
independent Canadian film and I'm just
curious you know my curiosity was piqued
and I kept seeing other than a warehouse
district and there's always these film
shoots with a lot of people's turn
around doing what I thought was sort of
nothing and so I was curious and so I
volunteered in the art department after
a couple years of architect you can
architect and a job came up a few days
later driving a cube truck moving
furniture for the septic department it
was kind of a good experience because
you know this was non-union small film
so sometimes I got stuck on set as the
on set props on set assistant I mean
props isn't and they're on set carpenter
on set painter and it just allowed you
to kind of see what happened and and
what mistakes might have been done by
the art department made it you know or
what could've been done better maybe to
make it easier to shoot sometimes on
sets so it was kind of a good experience
I did it for only about eight months or
so and then I decided I better I
realized then that oh the person the
people in charge of drawing these sets
was where I was most comfortable and I
my skills were most suited I was most
interested in so I've I had to figure
out how to join the the right guild the
arctor of actually in Canada it's called
the Directors Guild of Canada for us but
in America's director Actors Guild and
and once I joined then I had to pound
the pavement and try to find you know
get myself in the door and basically my
suggestions anyone who are trying to get
into the profession is really just get a
job in anything you can get a job in on
the film set at all because you meet you
get connections you kind of see where
you might fit in and it's it's never you
earn a little bit of money I mean it's
never a bad thing so I'm cheap of water
it was not a very big film at a 20 just
under twenty million dollars US dollars
and we had nine people in the art
department proper we had if people don't
understand what the hierarchy is the
sort of a production designer and then
there's a there's a big team it's not
just me that creates this world is a
huge team that collaborate together and
the art director or production designers
at the top then the art director sort of
does all the budgeting and scheduling of
all the things for the construction and
paint and then that that's a whole team
there's team and construction the team
and paint and then and then there's
another side which is the set decoration
team and that's who are also nominated
for
Baptists in this case Shane and Jeff and
they have another team to that deal with
all the set dressing and then there's
the whole prop Department so set
dressing is all the furnishings and
everything in curtains and other stuff
you see around props are all the hand
props that everyone touches and you know
books and things like that and and then
of course we're in charge of picture
cars you know we have to decide whether
or not you know and we have to worry
about the colors of all these things you
know the interior color has to work with
the costumes
just like the furnishings have to work
with the costume so even though costumes
are not under my sort of department or
or we work together you know Lois and I
work together right from the very
beginning where the color palette along
with Guillermo in this particular case
you know whose very color centric very
color concerned and and so it's a real
coordinated team and of course the DP
has to work with all of us to make sure
that you know he likes our light our
practical lighting everything when we
work with them to see in this case Dan
Loused and to see what he would like to
help for him to help shape his part of
the world as well so it's a real
collaborative effort and you know we're
always conversing back and forth but
ultimately it starts with the director
you know and we're always there to serve
his or her needs Jer mo is very like I
said very color centric the first day we
started with the office I mean I had the
script a whole year prior to that even
though I wasn't working on it that it
was percolating in my mind at least a
rough draft the first day we met we we
basically went through the big color
book and we quickly together we we
flipped through it all and associated
certain colors with certain characters
and one of the main characters is Eliza
Sally Hawkins character and her
apartment was basically in the aqua hues
you know she was supposed to be even
when there was no water it was always
meant to feel like she was in this aqua
world the movie opens with a dream sort
of sleeping dream sequence where we go
down the hallway into her apartment and
there's this caustic light flickering
through the you know water there was
digital water and done by a dry for wet
technique but after that once once that
she wakes up and settles in for the rest
of the movie we still wanted to keep
that sort of aqua tone and that that
feel of being slightly underwater so you
know in the script Guillermo had written
that light flickered through the
floorboards in the
the apartment from the theater below so
that was that ended up being like the
the flickering light that would come in
the dream sequence came from the above
as if it was the Sun rippling through
the water and then everything else in
there was kind of shaped by water all
the colors were in the aqua aqua blue
colors and our idea for that apartment
was that it was a Giles apartment was on
one side and Hurst was in the other but
it was split at one time rudely in the
in the 20s so there's sort of a deco Art
Deco detailed wall that went between but
on her side was the remnant Victorian
wallpaper from the building history
which was 1890s and then in that
wallpaper you know I had Shane sourced
had some beautiful wallpaper hand
printed wallpaper that were in the shape
of woodblock scales you know seems like
fish scales as a detail that you saw it
kind of at eye level and then everything
else was kind of you know quite brutally
aged and worn down from water leaking in
the ceiling and everything like that and
then opposite Jazz's apartment which is
very warm colours it was in sort of the
golds and mustards and and it was lit
warmly as well it meant to be a quite
different so you went from her cool blue
aqua tones across the hall into his warm
and his warm lit place to Dan lit his
side with sort of this Golden Hour kind
of lighting and on Eliza side it was
like always a steel blue kind of color
so it was like a real contrast but the
idea was that you know at some point
there was a grand room that got cut in
half she ended up in this rundown half
and he ended up in there really crowded
half and and he had a lot of he had more
means he had a bigger he must have come
from a house you know that was career as
an illustrator she had very little means
there was no art on the walls nothing
like that and and Guillermo said from
the beginning that the walls itself
would be like a piece of art so this is
where the heavy heavy aged patinated
walls that's where that derived from
he'd given me a photograph that he had
found online from a Indian photography
exhibit it was a real indigo blue wall
with heavy aging with distress on the
walls from humidity and he said I want
one of the walls to be like that and I
thought about it for a long time and
eventually I realized you know I can
use inspiration for anything to make
that whatever the texture and pattern on
the wall was and I chose I thought of
shapes of water literally shapes of
water in arts and I chose Hakka size
famous woodblock printing over the Great
Wave of Kenalog on so we superimpose
that in a drawing on one of the main
walls that we picked as our art wall and
then our scenic artist Matthew Lam Erick
painted it all in plaster very very
obvious like gimr walked in it goes oh
my god Paul it's like so literal I said
don't don't don't worry we're gonna
knock it way back and when we knocked it
way back essentially the mood was you
know there was this crashing wave that
went over top the entry door so anyone
coming into her world was just about to
be engulfed by water you know so that
was just these little subtle details in
that apartment that no one's ever gonna
know it without you listening to my
story but it's just we had to create a
little history for ourselves and it's
just some subliminal stuff I mean Jer mo
himself in previous movies that I've not
worked on he's done he's put little
subtle details in wallpaper patterns you
don't really see so I thought I'd take
take that idea what I understood that he
done it before and develop it somewhat
for this one so that's one world and
then we contrast that that world that
was meant to be romantic an old old
world is a you know curvaceous furniture
in her apartment we wanted to contrast
that with the the lab where she works
and the lab is kind of in for her it's a
bit of an oppressive place and I chose
again when I chose to use brutalist
concrete architecture style which was
you know I'm an architect when I was
prevalent from the 50s 60s and 70s an
institutional architecture pretty much
all over the world so it's a good it's a
good sort of base to get that that
oppressive institutional feeling and it
has harsh hard edges and harsh materials
and it was pretty much concrete in that
whole thing except for this there's some
tiles in the in there that ran through
the whole Lab and Guillermo in the
script had was a Cadillac dealership and
as a salesman pitching Michael Shannon
our villains character they say teal is
the color of the future and he's
pitching him on this teal colored car so
that collar we chose to run throughout
this whole world of the lab and mainly
it's just through these
sort of teal colored tiles which we
agonize that you spent many different we
went through so many different samples
to to get on with and test camera tests
to find one we really liked and that was
kind of a link that linked all the
studio sets and the locations we chose a
building from nineteen actually about
1964 so it's a bit later than our date
in Toronto was a University of Toronto
Andrews building it was this the
architect was named Andrews and it was
this pretty impressive building as an
exterior so we used it as an exterior
and some of the long one long hallway
with this automat that we built him
there and and then from there we took
that language and translated it into the
studio sets which were Strickland's
office and Strickland's command center
plus the elevator lobby and then the big
long hallway which looked endless which
was just 150 feet long ago we had green
screen on either end and then the lab
proper with the creature in it and that
was that was that real contrasting world
so we had the old world where she lived
at night and then or in the day I should
say and then at night when she came to
work she was in the sort of oppressive
kind of feeling place with Strickland
was purposely put up high because he
always looked down on everyone he looked
like he was above everyone so I
literally I placed his office above
everyone so that's kind of like that's
an example of two different worlds one
can create with color and texture and
materials
[Music]